president biden reacted to the shooting
by urging americans to fight the gun
violence epidemic the person of interest
in custody has a very similar profile to
murder suspects in uvalde texas and
buffalo new york senior investigative
correspondent captain herridge has more
on that catherine good morning
good morning nate the threat from
individuals who act by themselves
so-called lone wolf attacks is unfolding
with disturbing frequency the suspects
have been young men allegedly fueled by
grievances with access to high-powered
weapons a homeland security bulletin
from earlier this summer warned the
heightened threatened environment will
become more dynamic in the coming months
and that lone offenders in groups could
target public gatherings faith-based
institutions schools racial ethnic and
religious minorities as well as the
media from the may supermarket shooting
in buffalo new york to the elementary
school attack in uvalde texas and now
the person of interest in highland park
all are young men aged 21 or under
speaking to cbs news on sunday the
homeland security secretary did warn
that a growing number of issues divide
americans and this he said adds to the
already high threat environment these
so-called lone wolf attacks can be among
the hardest for law enforcement to
disrupt because they can cross the
threshold from hateful speech online
which can have first amendment
protections to violence very quickly
vlad
yeah kathryn you mentioned it young men
with access to high-powered weapons and
they have grievances perceived
grievances catherine thank you very much